I wanted to ask you cuz uh you obviously
shouts to The Higher Learning podcast
but what's it like working with a guy
like Bill Simmons that's great cuz I
listen to The Bill Simmons pod I've been
listening for like [__] 10 years I
mean almost every almost literally
almost every episode so here's the thing
so imagine that you're a person like
myself right and you have all of these
varied interests you're probably the
number one guy in terms of wrestling MH
cuz you're you're on rewatchables a lot
too not now but in history right I'm on
you know and but you love that you love
movies you love sports you love politics
you love history uh you are very
invested into Black Culture you have uh
thoughts on so many different things
video games Marvel all that right and
then there's one place that somebody
knows how to give you the opportunity to
uh Express develop and utilize those
talents and those interests it's not
just about the fact that you're good at
talking cuz I think that if you talk
enough you'll get good at it right um
and if you get blind to the camera then
you'll do your thing sorry James Andre
Jefferson Jr just finished a
workout we're in a competition I'm
listening one place I'm
listening I'm listening see that N I
like my job [__] it no go ahead since
you going to check your watch while I'm
doing my [__] go ahead I like no no I'm
listening I'm list that's enough that's
enough that's enough that's on the
that's on the that's on McKinley High
I'm not finishing that [__]
well I got to make sure I always I have
make sure it's not my kid or my wife
that's always but if your kid has an
emergency right now you're sitting down
with the [__] who told Kanye off I
think you got to make decisions you know
what I'm saying like that that to me
that to me is disrespectful yeah Daddy
Daddy I need ice cream Daddy Daddy I
skin my knee hey your kid's name is
Justin right hey no my kid's name's not
Justin probably probably is it's Aiden
either first of all both my kids are
mixed Justin or Aiden see how close that
is aen and
Millennium [__] what yeah Millennium
yeah my 10-year-old's name is Millennium
yeah Millennium yeah what they I mean
there's got to be a
story uh so me and my wife black lady no
she's Mexican but my uh my son
Millennium is so we met when he was
three so I have an 18-year-old from my
previous relationship right um who I've
had custody the whole time me and my
girl when we started dating her son is
three but he's never met his dad so uh
she was watching TV one day uh and there
was like a millennium Productions at the
end of a TV show or something and she
was like nobody else is going to name
their kid this I want a one of one name
now she was right about that so we call
him Millie Millennium Millie yeah it's
that really the hip-hop [__] again the
cactus t-shit ailly ailly ailly ailly no
but he's he's a what is he into he r no
he plays basketball no he's he's Mexican
black and Puerto Rican oh man yeah he
about to be hell on these hoes man yeah
that's a crazy no he's a big he's he's a
big big Hooper though he does like what
do he play like uh he play with Matt
kids or something like that uh we he's
in this Burbank league and then he does
this aou tournament and sure uh Thousand
Oaks what are you like as a basketball
dad are you like
um let me pick up the Bill Simmons
question real quick because I want to
finish this so I I enjoy working with
the ringer I enjoy working with the
ringer because I'll say this this last
sence it's one thing to go to a place
where your talent is utilize it's
another place to work at a place where
your
interests right are utilized different
it's different your talent being
utilized means hey you're good at
talking about something we're going to
make you talk about this thing you don't
really care about that much so that you
can uh do something for us cuz we need
you to fill a spot well like for like
rewatchables do you like tell them like
hey if you ever do this movie I want to
be a like that's my [__] not necessarily
but it it'll it'll be a situation to
where it's like hey uh do you like this
movie or you'll get a list of movies
like hey tell us which ones you like
yeah and then tell ones you like watch
was [__] amazing it's a great podcast
just think about it so think about how
pure it is it's just a podcast about
rewatching old movies and talk about
talking about what the movie meant
culturally what you care how much you
care about the movie where you were at
the time